Okay, so the markets are open this
morning and
looks like we have looking at a 15-inute
chart of the NASDAQ.
It's pretty much we had a big selloff
Friday and we kind of just gave it back
up and we're kind of just in the middle
of this uh which doesn't give great
trade potential. Looking at a big
picture, this is technically the S&P 500
future, but same thing, it's just in a
sloppy uptrend. This is on a daily chart
and going at 15 minute of the S&P 500
futures. Kind of same thing. And so what
I'm looking for here is
maybe it comes down to this uptrend or
maybe it comes down to this overnight
like kind of double bottom range that
it's in and we kind of get a bounce to
go higher. but unlikely to really see
something
um just because of where it is. You
know, I like to trade on the extremes,
you know, like I like to see a big move
near a support level that looks like
it's likely to reverse. Now, oil here on
a 30 minute and also 15 minute, it's had
this selloff and then kind of a nice
bounce here and it's pretty much come up
to this area. I think looking at a big
picture, this
is still, you know, it's had a big
bounce here, but I think it's likely
that it comes down somewhere down here
or further before it really
if it switches trends. Um
just because you know like if you look
at here it had this big selloff down
here
big bounce and then kind of retested.
All these big moves kind of sit in this
area for a while. They unlikely very
rarely have a huge Vbottom where it just
goes up. you know, this is a crazy
pretty big B bottom, but big picture,
it's likely to have kind of a move here
at least um that we can capture. And so
there I want to look for
on a fivem minute chart. I want to see
it come up and test I want to put in a
sell order. Um I want to see it come up
and test kind of this area. Ideally, it
comes up, bounces, and then goes lower,
and I can get it short somewhere here.
Uh and then gold.
gold on Friday. I liked the potential
for a short right here, but it just
didn't really set up. Um, and it looks
like we've just kind of continued to
rocket higher. Uh, and
I kind of think it looks a little
overextended right now and it's already
kind of having a pullback. I think it
maybe comes down here and bounces.
Um, looking at a fiveminute chart
because it's it's just kind of slowly
petering higher and so it got a little
overextended here. It's going to have a
pullback, but big picture, gold is just
so strong. I don't want to be trying to
short it. Even if it does a nice move
like this, the higher probability is
waiting for it to come back to the
uptrend and then going long. So, that's
kind of what I'm looking for today.
Seems like it might be a quiet day, but
you kind of just never know.
Do I short here?
It's a hard question because it just
seems like it's
big picture. It just looks like,
you know, we're retesting this area, but
it just doesn't feel like the ES is just
choppy.
NASDAQ is just
I think it gives this up.
Big picture. We're at a nice level.
We're at a good timing.
I'm going to take smaller size.
There's good riskreward if it does get
going. It has made kind of a nice
pullback here.
I probably need to have my stop up here
though, which is kind of bummer because
it shits on the riskreward a little bit.
Going here would be kind of nicer.
Just because the riskreward is what here
is 3x versus if I put it up here
that's 2x.
And I think if it pops up here again,
I want to see it's showing some
volatility. I want to see how this
candle plays out because it looks like
it could just spike lower here and then
go up. Like it looks like it wants to do
a bullish candle. Wow. I'm really glad
glad I didn't get in short right there.
I think I'm going to get short though if
it breaks below this candle.
I'm still going to do small size.
You know, it could just be coming down
here and continuing higher. But again,
it's at a big picture spot I like.
And so that's what I'm going off of.
I think I'm probably just going to try
and see if I can get 2x out of this
depending on what the market does here.
that big of a spike lower. That's pretty
sad.
So, my plan with this is
I'll probably move to break even once it
kind of gets down here. And then I think
I'm going to
I'm probably going to take most of it
off, if not all of it. pretty much a 2x
depending on what this these
candlesticks start to look like. Uh just
because that's kind of the overnight
highs is a spot where it could find a
bounce.
Um and that's kind of down there. You
know, it choppy market. It' be nice to
get something, but you know, totally uh
possible to not. Um so just kind of
waiting this out. And if you haven't
checked it out, Ninja Trader has a free
trading contest for demo trading for new
or returning customers where you can
pretty much just demo trade for a week.
It comes out really, really soon and
it's a contest and you can win real
money from it. Basically trading
risk-free. So really good way to
basically just make money trading
without risk. You can check it out in
the link in the description below. I'm
going to move to break even here.
And I'm also just going to since this is
kind of getting going.
O, those those pullbacks like that are
rough. I want to see what the ES is
doing. The ES is the ES is pretty much
at the overnight highs.
I think I'm just going to just with how
because this isn't a massive move up
like very one directional. It's like
this. I'm just going to get out at 2x.
I'd rather kind of just because it's
choppy. It's likely to be choppy again.
And so I I'm happy to just kind of get
out.
Looks like it's going to break lower
here. Just kind of doing a little mini
bare flag. Just being patient.
Looks like we're in a hit. I'm going to
move. If it just starts to just barely
not make it, I'm going to move my stop
down to here.
It would really suck to get knocked out
here at not hitting 2x. I think I'm
going to move it here. Um, just to look
at this. It's got kind of got a
downtrend like this.
It would really suck to kind of just get
there and then basically give back $400
for going for 50.
But, you know, that's kind of part of
trading. I could have moved it here.
I just felt like giving it a little bit
of wiggle room was smart. But out of
600,
kind of rough because it still could
totally go down. But
I'm trying to be strict with a choppy